an increased amount
joe biden finally admitting there's a
crisis at the border as he defends his
initial moves on the refugee camp well
this is though
after 26 days 26 days without a press
conference for kamala harris
who is supposedly in charge of the
border surge
joe biden has called on her to fix it
we'll see our next guest says she
never should have gotten this role in
the first place foxness contributor and
the hill media opinion columnist joe
concha joins us now to explain so joe
why should she never have gotten this
job to begin with
oh there's several reasons i wouldn't
even call it a crisis anymore jed i
would call it
a catastrophe at the border and her past
statements
should have disqualified her from the
president even considering her despite
the fact
that she's the vice president she
compared ice to the kkk
she said that illegal border crossings
should be legal she said these things as
a senator
and as a candidate so those are your two
positions how do you possibly fix
a situation like this and look it's
painfully apparent now
that you will not see kamala harris at
the border you'll see the detroit lions
in the super bowl
before you see kamala harris at the
border and as well and probably lawrence
knows
the lions have never been to a super
bowl just like you'll probably never see
the vice president there because she'll
have to answer questions
around her past policy positions on
what's going on
at the border and this seems to be
something that even though she's in
charge even of the diplomacy side in
terms of guatemala and nicaragua
and mexico she hasn't even traveled
there to speak about this and don't tell
me it's because of covet restrictions
because at last check
she is fully vaccinated and the cdc says
it's perfectly fine
for her to travel or to meet with people
indoors even without a mass so there
goes that excuse jed
sounds like a segment on the will kane
podcast jared goff and the lions or
kamala harris which reaches success
first i might have to do that
joke um joe do they want to fix it do
they want to fix it putting someone in
charge like kamala harris who
as you just pointed out has a history of
showing really
no interest in a secure border really
leads to the question
do they want to fix it that's the
question right and you
think about kamala harris personally
there are more than a few people that
believe that she will be
the democratic nominee in 2024 and not
joe biden because then you're talking
about
an 80-something joe biden maybe he just
wanted to serve one term he hasn't
completely and totally definitively said
that he will
run for president again then so then
people will look at okay
in terms of your accomplishments kamala
harris
what did you do for instance with the
biggest responsibility that you had as
vice president
in terms of fixing our border
catastrophe and she won't
probably have many answers because again
you look at these facilities
dangerously overcrowded you hear reports
now
of sexual assault of young girls this is
the same candidate in harris by the way
who compared these facilities that
you're currently seeing where you're not
seeing because there's a media blackout
but the pictures that do get out
uh concerning babies in cages she called
it well now she's not doing much to
help those babies in cages so this will
be her signature
failure and any republican that runs
against her like a ron desantis or even
a donald trump will be very quick to
point this out she's not going to have
any answers to uh
to talk about him joe but did they need
to really even appoint someone to do
this job i mean mayorkas
he knows he was the deputy before joe
biden knows he was the vice president
they know what they need to do to get a
handle of this are they just refusing to
it seems they are i think my orchestra
has been set up to be the fall guy
lawrence to be honest with you like they
could always just point to him
as saying that okay well he's in charge
of dhs this is his responsibility
but it just seems like they hope this
will go away
eventually but here we are in april the
weather will get even warmer in may this
is only going to get worse but
you have to have a media that is
demanding accountability here and that
means access to all facilities
access to all border patrol agents and
an interest in actually covering it
on major places like the evening news
work believe it or not they're still
getting 25 million viewers a night when
you add up cbs abc
nbc fox is covering it obviously we're
talking about it but msnbc and cnn don't
seem to have much of an interest there
so until the new york times in the
washington post
everybody in unison gets together like
they did with donald trump in terms of
what they call the crisis
uh i think they think they can get away
with it because they have a complicit
media that
doesn't seem to have much interest in
solving this problem while you're at
least covering it the administration has
essentially said look we'll give you
access when we get ready so i won't hold
my breath on that thanks so much for
joining the program thanks